[Musique]
m
en fait quel est le nom de cette étrange
instrument qu'il avait ça s'appelle la
cornemuse à gaz et vous aurez de
l'inventaire et comment vous est venue
l'idée de fabriquer un tel instrument
oh ben ça date déjà depuis longtemps ma
grand-mère jouer de la cornemuse et moi
même je suis enfant n'a connu ça lors
d'une soumis à jouer j'ai mis longtemps
à fabriquer cet instrument là assez
longtemps sa demande est quand même pas
mal de soirées une dimanche est-ce que
c'est au point maintenant oui malgré
quelques petites retouches dans les
notes
quels sont les avantages de cet
instrument ben ça pas mal davantage vu
que le bourdon est quand même assez
réduit ça permet de passer sous les
portes et sont moins encombrants et
aussi c'est beaucoup moins fatigant du
moment qui a pu la poche à remplir j'ai
plus qu'à ouvrir une bouteille la poche
remplie et ça me permet aussi en même
temps de de chanter dessus de fumer la
cigarette au besoin parce que c'est pas
dangereux et du gaz que le bella au nom
du moment donné par l'intérieur
vous pensez que ça aura du succès
insolent vont très certainement oui j'ai
déposé un brevet oui oui oui les partis
et je pense que ça marchera peut-être
dans le cadre de la régionalisation peut
être peut-être qu'avec une industrie
nouvelle pour la bretagne
il m'a eu comment ça fonctionne
exactement ben ça fonctionne par les
bouteilles j'ouvre mes bouteilles ça
remplit la poche et ça nous permet de
jouer
vous pouvez nous faire une démonstration
vous bien sûr
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai plus de gaz
c'est la panne je obligé d'ailleurs
rechange et une bouteille
[Musique]